N
THE BORDER OR THE PRESS
CONFERENCES.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO
VISIT THE BORDER?
>> AT SOME POINT.
WE ARE GOING TO THE BORDER,
WE'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER, SO
THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT THE
BORDER -- WE'VE BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
WE'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN'T BEEN TO EUROPE.
>> Greg: MAYBE YOU SHOULD GET
OUT THERE PRINCESS PANTS.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE SHE LAUGHS
AND SHE'S WEARING PANTS.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WELL, THAT DIDN'T END
WELL.
AND SPEAKING OF CATS NIGHT OUT
LAST NIGHT...
[INDISTINCT]
>> Greg: SHE LEAVES A WAKE OF
DAMAGED FURNITURE.
I ALSO THINK OF ACTRESS ELLIE
KEMPER FOLD INTO THE WELCOME.
HERE'S A RECAP FROM THE MOST
HANDSOME MAN ON TELEVISION.
ELLIE KEMPER, STAR OF THE
OFFICE, IS UNDER ATTACK AFTER
ALL NINE IDIOTS DECLARED SHE WAS
A RACIST.
HER CRIME?
IN 1999 A ST. LOUIS BUSINESS
GROUP NAMED HER THEIR QUEEN OF
LOVE AND BEAUTY P OF THE GROUP
USED TO BE A WHITES ONLY, BUT
INTEGRATED 20 YEARS BEFORE SHE
WON HER CROWN.
20 YEARS.
>> IT'S HARD TO ABSORB THE NEWS
WHEN IT'S COMING FROM SOMEONE
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
NOW, WHEN WE DID THE SEGMENT, WE
SALUTED HER FOR NOT RESPONDING
TO THE TWITTER MOB CALLING FOR
HER SCALP.
NO OFFENSE, ELIZABETH WARREN.
BUT THAT'S HOW YOU BEAT COUNCIL
CULTURE PURITY REALIZE IT'S JUST
A DOZEN LOSERS SCREAMING FOR
ATTENTION FROM A THE MEDIA.
YOU LET THEM SCREAM UNTIL THEY
SCREAM THEMSELVES OUT, THAT'S
WHAT MY MOM DID TO ME IN THE
WOODS.
WITHOUT KEMPER COME OUT IT
WOULD'VE BEEN LIKE KATIE PLATH
WHICH GOING THROUGH A HANGOVER.
BUT SADLY JUST DAYS LATER,
KEMPER GRAVEL TO THE WOKE POLICE
OFFERING NOT JUST AN APOLOGY,
BUT A CONFESSION.
IT EMBARRASSED JOHN CENA.
I KNOW, I KNOW.
IT HAD ALL THE WOKE
CATCHPHRASES, AND I QUOTE, I
DEPLORE AND DENOUNCE WHITE
SUPREMACY.
AT THE SAME TIME MAY RECOGNIZE
THAT BECAUSE OF MY RACE AND
PRIVILEGE I AM THE BENEFICIARY
OF A SYSTEM THAT DISPENSES
UNEQUAL JUSTICE AND UNEQUAL
REWARDS.
POWs PICK MORE OFF-THE-CUFF
THAN THAT.
BUT SHE FOLLOWS THE SCRIPT.
AS A VERY NATURAL TEMPTATION
WHEN YOU BECOME THE SUBJECT TO
TELL YOURSELF THAT THEY ARE
GETTING IT ALL WRONG.
BUT I REALIZE THAT A LOT OF THE
FORCES BEHIND THE CRITICISM ARE
FORCES THAT HAVE SPENT MY LIFE
SUPPORTING AND AGREEING WITH.
DID JANE FONDA WRITE THIS?
SHE THEN SAID SHE WAS GRATEFUL
FOR HER HUMILIATION AND TELLS US
THAT SHE WILL USE OR PRIVILEGE
AND SUPPORT OF A BETTER SOCIETY
I THINK WE ARE CAPABLE OF
BECOMING.
WELL HOW A NAUSEATING OF HER.
SO WHAT IF WE ALL FOLLOWED HER
LEAD.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON PLAYING PRO
BASEBALL HAS TO APOLOGIZE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN A LEAGUE THAT
ONCE SEGREGATED BLACKS.
THAT ALSO INCLUDES BASEBALL
FANS, BASEBALL CAP WEARERS, AND
ANYBODY HAS TRIED TO GET TO
SECOND BASE ON A DATE.
ALSO EVERY DEMOCRAT MUST
APOLOGIZE AND DEMAND A NAME
CHANGE FOR THE POLITICAL PARTY,
IT WAS THE PARTY OF SLAVERY AND
JIM CROW AFTER ALL BRITT THEY
FOUGHT A WAR TO KEEP BID THEY
EVEN GAVE A EULOGY FOR A
DEMOCRAT LEADER WHO WAS A KKK
GRAND -- WHATEVER THEY CALL EACH
OTHER.
SO THINK ABOUT THIS, KEMPER WAS
A DEBUTANTE.
WHEN SHE DIDN'T KNOW WAS RACIST
BEFORE SHE WAS EVEN BORN.
BUT EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT BECAME
A DEMOCRAT KNOWING THAT THEY
WERE ONCE THE PARTY OF SLAVERY.
AS PEOPLE OFTEN SAY TO ME IN THE
SAUNA, WOW, THAT CAN'T BE RIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
I NEVER KNOW WHAT GETS A LAUGH
THESE DAYS.
I UNDERSTAND KEMPER, SHE'S
TERRIFIED OF BEING OSTRACIZED
LIKE MOST ACTORS THEY
DESPERATELY WANT TO BE LIKED AND
THEY CAN'T SPEAK UNLESS THEY
HAVE A SCRIPT AND A CONSULTANT.
WITHOUT THAT, THEY ARE
VULNERABLE TO THE WORST TYPE OF
GROUPTHINK.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
♪ ♪
>> I'M NOT WORRIED, I CAN'T BE
CANCELED.
MY MAINSTREAM CAREER WAS
DESTROYED YEARS AGO WHEN I MET A
GUY NAMED GREG GUTFELD.
THANKS, GREG.
♪ ♪
>> YOU ARE WELCOME.
HOW ABOUT THE ANGRY BLACK MALE?
♪ ♪
>> WHAT'S UP?
SO SOMEBODY HAS TO APOLOGIZE FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED LONG
BEFORE THEY WERE BORN?
AND WHEN THEY JOIN, THEY DON'T
DESERVE IT ANYMORE?
SO I GUESS THAT KIND OF
THINKING...
I GUESS DEMOCRATS ARE ALL IN THE
CLAN?
♪ ♪
>> Greg: THAT WAS KEMPER'S
TIME IN THE BARREL.
IT BEGAN WITH AN OLD PHOTO AND
BECAME A TWITTER TREND.
IN FACT, IF YOU LOOK AT ANY MOB
ACTION COMMIT ALWAYS STARTS THAT
WAY.
WITH SOMETHING CALLED TWITTER
TRENDS BARELY SHOW YOU WHAT
PEOPLE ARE CLICKING ON WHICH
THEN BECOMES AN ATTENTION
GENERATOR, MUCH LIKE CHRIS
CUOMO.
REMEMBER UNCLE TIM?
WITHOUT TWITTER TREND, NO ONE
WOULD'VE HEARD OF IT.
MANIPULATED BY THE LEGACY MEDIA
PROMOTED WITH A DISHONESTLY
EDITED CLIPS AND THEN THERE'S
TRUMP FEEDING THE FISH,
MIKE PENCE LOADING EMPTY BOXES,
TRUMP WEARING HIS PANTS
BACKWARDS.
TWITTER TRENDS CREATED THESE
FAKE STORIES.
IT IS HUB FOR ELECTIVES.
AND LIKE THE WUHAN LAB, ALL YOU
NEED TO DO IS CREATE ONE SOURCE
AND THEN UNLEASH IT.
TWITTER TRENDS DO THE REST.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE MEDIA'S
TROUGH.
TRENDS ARE THE EASIEST STORIES
TO WRITE, AND THEY PLAY UPON
OUTRAGE ADDICTS WHO HAVE NO
LIVES BID MY THEORY IS THAT
ELIMINATED -- THE WORLD WOULD
INSTANTLY BECOME ANOTHER PLACE.
SUBJECT, IT'S NOT HOURS OF
FASTING AND MEDICATION OR THAT
STUPID AMISH CHIN THAT'S GOING
TO MAKE YOU A BETTER PERSON.
IT'S REMOVING THE PART OF YOUR
SITE THAT DESTROYS LIVES.
UNTIL YOU DO THAT, WE SHALL SIT
BY AND WATCH THE ENDLESS PARADE
OF COWARD IS JUST UP AS A LIGHT
MEANT AS TWITTER FEEDS ON THE
CADAVER OF CAREERS.
AND THE CONTRITION WILL ALL BE
AN ACT.
SADLY, IT'S THE BEST ACTING SOME
OF THE CELEBRITIES DO.
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE IS SO SHARP, FORMER DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL ECONOMIC --
LARRY CARLO.
WHEN SHE LEFT ARIZONA THE
TEMPERATURE DROPPED 20 DEGREES,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KATIE
PLIABLE HER.
SHE IS LIKE A PRAYING MANTIS,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR CAT.
AND FINALLY, MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: LAWRENCE COME YOU'VE
BEEN A WHITE GUY FOR A WHILE.
>> WHAT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
ALL THIS WOKE STUFF?
DO YOU THINK IT WAS RIGHT FOR
HER TO APOLOGIZE?
>> NO, I DON'T THAT SHE SHOULD
HAVE APOLOGIZED BRITT OUT OF IT
SHE HAD ANY IDEA WHEN SHE WAS 19
YEARS OLD IN ST. LOUIS WHAT,
WHEN, WHERE, AND HOW.
NO IDEA.
JUST BEING WOKED BY THE TWITTER
MOB.
>> Greg: WHEN I WAS A
DEBUTANTE I HAD NO IDEA.
I DIDN'T LOOK UP THE PAST RACIST
ABUSES OF THE PEOPLE THAT MAY BE
A DEBUTANTE.
>> THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WAS THE
DRESS YOU DECIDED TO WEAR.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
SPEAK OF THE FASHION CHOICES YOU
DECIDED, THOSE PICTURES WILL
HOPEFULLY NEVER COME OUT.
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF PICTURES
THAT NEVER COME OUT, HAVE YOU
EVER DONE ANYTHING ON INSTAGRAM?
>> ON INSTAGRAM?
THAT'S PUBLIC.
>> Greg: DO WE HAVE ANYTHING
FROM HER INSTAGRAM WE CAN SHOW?
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT IS THAT?
YOU ARE LETTING A DOG EAT A
BABY.
ED FILLED ME THAT!
>> THIS IS FAKE NEWS, HE'S
ACTUALLY SAVING THE BABY.
HE WAS ALERTING US THAT THE BABY
MAY NEED SAVING FOR YOUR
THOUGHTS WHAT HE WAS DOING WAS
DOING.
>> Greg: BOY DO I HAVE EGG ON
MY FACE.
>> HE'S TOO CUTE TO COUNSEL.
>> Greg: IS HE NOW SAY FROM
CANCELLATION?
>> SHE SAFE BECAUSE SHE'S A
DEMOCRAT, AND IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT YOU CAN GIVE EULOGIES
AT FUNERALS FOR KKK MEMBERS AND
FELLOW DEMOCRATS.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT AS
LONG AS YOU ACKNOWLEDGE AND SAY
YOU HAVE WHITE PRIVILEGE AND TRY
TO MOVE ON.
SHE WILL BE FINE.
>> Greg: WHEN WE DID THIS
ORIGINAL STORY, YOU ARE SO PROUD
OF HER.
YOU SAID THAT BECAUSE SHE WASN'T
GOING TO RESPOND, AND THEN WHAT
DID SHE DO?
SHE BETRAYED YOU.
>> BEFORE WE GO THERE, I WARNED
YOU.
BUT YOU ARE JUST A BIG MAN,
AREN'T YOU?
YOU ARE JUST A BIG MAN.
FOR THE SHOW WAS OVER TONIGHT
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU HOW BIG HE
REALLY IS, BUT I DIGRESS.
I AM GOING TO CHANNEL MY INNER
WHITE WOMAN AND I'M GOING TO
GIVE WHITE AMERICA SOME ADVICE.
THE NEXT TIME SOMEONE TELLS YOU
YOU HAVE WHITE PRIVILEGE OR YOU
SHOULD BE ASHAMED, DO WHAT WE
DO.
I'M HERE BECAUSE I WORKED HARD,
I STARTED, I WENT TO COLLEGE, I
AUDITIONED.
IF YOU WANT MY SPOT, COME GET
IT.
I'M NOT JUST GOING TO COME GIVE
IT TO YOU.
THE COLOR OF MY SKIN HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH IT.
EVERY TIME -- YOU ONLY GOT THIS
JOB BECAUSE YOU ARE BLACK, I'M
LIKE, BLACK -- I DID THAT.
SO START FIGHTING BACK WITH
FACTS AND NOT APOLOGIZING FOR
SOMETHING YOU HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO DEAL WITH.
>> I REALLY LOVE THAT.
I JUST LOVE THAT.
BUT I'M SITTING HERE, IT'S THE
FIRST TIME WE'VE BEEN ON STAGE
TOGETHER, AND BASICALLY SCARED
TO DEATH.
>> Greg: DON'T WORRY, HE'S
GOING TO KILL ME.
>> NOT QUITE THERE YET AMERICA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHEN I'M IN THE ALLEY, YOU GO
THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S HARD ON MY CHEST.
I PROMISE.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE A BIG HEART
ON YOUR CHEST.
>> I TOLD YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WHAT IF I DIDN'T
WRITE THAT JOKE?
WHAT IF I BLAME IT ON ONE OF MY
WRITERS.
>> I KNOW TOM, I KNOW KAT.
I KNOW YOU DID IT.
>> Greg: SO KAT, HERE'S AN
INTERESTING FACT I LEARNED
TODAY.
DID YOU KNOW TWITTER TRENDS ARE
BASED ON REALLY SMALL NUMBERS?
OVER A SIX HOUR PERIOD AND GET
TWITTER TRENDY.
THAT IS NOTHING.
>> IT MAKES MY BRAIN SCRAMBLE.
THAT IS WHY I GOT MARRIED.
HE CAN DO THE TAXES.
I HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM WITH HER
APOLOGY, I WILL SAY THAT.
THE PART WHERE SHE SAID SHE DID
NOT KNOW THAT IT WAS ELITIST
LIKE BRO, IT WAS A BALL.
NORMAL 19-YEAR-OLDS -- WE DIDN'T
GO TO BALLS.
WE WENT TO DOLLAR PICTURE NIGHT
AND HOPE THEY DIDN'T CHECK
IDs.
IT'S NOT LIKE SHE JUST REALIZED
OH, I WAS RICH.
SHE GREW UP INCREDIBLY RICH.
HER GREAT-GRANDFATHER STARTED
WHAT HAS BEEN CALLED A DYNASTY
OF BANKERS.
THIS IS WHAT I WAS GOOGLING.
SHE WAS SUPER RICH PRETHERE WAS
A MUSEUM NAMED AFTER HER
GRANDMA.
DON'T ACT LIKE YOU HAD NO
IDEA -- YOU NEVER GOT
STREP THROAT IN THE McDONALD'S
PLAY PLACE LIKE THE REST OF US.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> HOW DARE SHE BE BORN INTO A
RICH FAMILY.
WHAT WAS SHE THINKING?
>> SHE SAID SHE DIDN'T KNOW THE
RICH LADY BALL SHE WENT TO WAS
ELITIST.
>> THERE'S A MUSEUM NOW THANKS
TO YOU, LET THEM KNOW.
>> Greg: HOW CAN SHE POSSIBLY
KNOW THAT SOME 19-YEAR-OLD KID
IS GOING TO THIS DEB PARTY --
HOW COULD SHE KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS?
AND WHY, 30 YEARS LATER, DOES
SHE --
>> Greg: THIS IS AN
EX-BOYFRIEND.
THIS IS MY THEORY.
HE'S BEEN HOLDING ON THIS
PICTURE FOREVER.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO.
>> IF THIS IS THE WORST GUILT
TRIP I'VE EVER SEEN.
YOU ARE SO RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
BE PROUD OF IT, HAVE A GOOD
TIME.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN, JUST GO
OUT THERE AND DANCE AND GO TO
BALLS AND HAVE DEBUTANTE
PARTIES.
BIG DEAL.
>> YOU ARE MAKING PROGRESS,
LARRY, LARRY.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW I WAS POOR
UNTIL I GOT TO COLLEGE.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
BE ONE I DIDN'T KNOW I WAS SHORT
UNTIL I GOT TO HIGH SCHOOL.
[L